y el de hace 10 años.
Yo pongo el mío en la pantalla para ayudarles.
Ahora le pedimos a las personas
que predigan, que nos cuenten,
cuánto dinero pagarían ahora
para ver a su artista favorito actual
en un concierto dentro de 10 años,
y, en promedio, dijeron que pagarían
USD 129 por esa entrada.
Y cuando les preguntamos cuánto pagarían
para ver actuar hoy a quien fue
su artista favorito hace 10 años,
dijeron que solo pagarían USD 80.
En un mundo perfectamente racional,
este debería ser el mismo número,
pero pagamos de más por la oportunidad
de satisfacer nuestras preferencias actuales
porque sobreestimamos su estabilidad.
¿Por qué ocurre esto? No estamos totalmente seguros,
pero probablemente tenga que ver
con la facilidad de recordar
versus la dificultad de imaginar.
Muchos podemos recordar quiénes éramos hace 10 años,
pero nos resulta difícil imaginar quiénes seremos,
y entonces pensamos erróneamente que como es difícil de imaginar,
no es probable que suceda.
Lo siento, cuando decimos "No puedo imaginarlo",
por lo general hablamos de nuestra propia falta de imaginación
y no de la falta de probabilidad
de los eventos que describimos.
Como conclusión: el tiempo es una fuerza poderosa.
Transforma nuestras preferencias.
Retoca nuestros valores.
Altera nuestras personalidades.
Parece que apreciamos este hecho,
pero solo en retrospectiva.
Solo al mirar hacia atrás nos damos cuenta
del gran cambio ocurrido en una década.
Es como si, para muchos de nosotros,
el presente fuese un tiempo mágico.
Es una divisoria de aguas en la línea de tiempo.
Es el momento en el cual finalmente
nos tornamos nosotros mismos.
Los seres humanos somos obras en curso
y por error pensamos que estamos concluidos.
La persona que uno es ahora
es tan transitoria, fugaz y temporal
como todas las personas que uno ha sido.
Lo único constante en nuestra vida es el cambio.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)